This equation represents a hyperbola that opens to the left and to the right.
Now we might not recognize the hyperbola in this form. So, let's subtract y
squared from both sides of the equation. This'll move the y squared to the
left-hand side, so we'll have x squared minus y squared equals positive 9 on
the right. We have subtraction between our x squared term and our y squared
term, so we know this is a hyperbola. Further more, we know that this parabola
opens to the left and to the right since the x squared term is positive. It's
the one that comes first. Now it's not so much which one comes first, but it's
really the one that's positive determines the direction. Since the x squared
term is positive, we know it opens left and right. And just to be sure, I'll
show you this graph to tell you that these graphs are identical. The equations
represent the same hyperbola.